she returns he's a host of Artie's going
underground show joining us live now
thank you hi thanks coming on short
notice there have so now it's it's
being viewed in London then surprise
move we'll call it schooi yeah i think
it surprised lots of journalists but
then there's a word in the English
language Kremlinology which signifies a
kind of shady murky analysis of
government changes for a reason people
don't really understand russia in the
outside world arguably in fact arguably
it is it is done in any analysis blinded
by russophobia in NATO nations any
comment from Moscow any news for Moscow
usually gets a pretty quick response I
was just on the phone with the Foreign
Office they say they don't have a
response the Foreign Office in London to
the changes announced that you've just
been discussing in Russia which seemed
really revolutionary Putin certainly
seems to have rubbed out any mass
coverage of things like free internet
and minimum wage allocations and and the
indexation of pensions this is all about
what is gonna happen in Russia and I
have to say that already one can see the
usual suspects as it were saying this
this is all about Putin consolidating he
wants to be in power after 2020 for
which he said he was gonna leave house
he viewed these days in Britain people
like a steady hand on that on the keel
don't they and they also like a familiar
face and like him or not he's a familiar
face so Arthur is he is his departure as
Prime Minister going to be viewed in a
good or bad light in Britain well
through the prism of NATO nation media
Russia is considered a one not even a
one-party state a one man state complete
utter autocracy run by Vladimir Putin no
matter what he had said no matter what
some of the deputies might say in the
coming days or even the election
councilors it prefer prepares for a
referendum on the constitutional changes
announced by Vladimir Putin and mr.
Medvedev they will be watching all this
through that prism and be claiming that
anything that comes
Moscow is all about a conspiratorial
cabal that runs a country as big as what
about the observers what about the
observers will say today well no this is
effective about power in Russia being
moved more to the legislature more to
the legislative branch
they'll scoff at that will a they will
completely scoff at that and believe
this is a power grab and of course this
kind of arguable disinformation about
understanding other countries not just
Russia limits the ability of these
countries are understanding other places
in in the world of course you could be
forgiving about Russia because of course
here in Britain the intelligence
services were so taken over by Soviet
agents during the so-called Cold War so
perhaps as an excuse here but we're
still awaiting comment from I think the
White House let alone 10 Downing Street
what's worrying of course is that while
journalists perhaps can be forgiven for
thinking this a big surprise in terms of
Russian history and we've got to
remember its historical month the
Russian liberation of Auschwitz is being
talking about in this country without
reference to the Russian army or Russian
involvement in World War two well while
journalists can be forgiven the
intelligence agencies the foreign
ministers the think tanks they should
have they should arguably be
understanding what is going on in Russia
after all these these are nuclear-armed
countries Russia has a big nuclear
arsenal I would suggest that the level
of ignorance through this prism of
russophobia is is quite breathtaking
just a final thought ok this is that
this is an internal thing you feel like
but how is it going to affect any
changes at the top how's it going to
affect foreign policy regarding Russia
regarding Britain well at the moment the
United Party in Russia is what 335 out
of 450 seats we'll have to see how this
turns out in elections because of course
as as you been reporting if this gives
more power to the legislature what will
it mean for Russian foreign policy
Britain
the United States NATO I'm sure these
countries arguably seek an enemy many
policy analysts seeing that in fact
there are NATO countries that define
themselves by their opposition to Moscow
whether it be foreign policy or the fact
that Russia has been advancing in
certain virtual contexts over the past
few years after it's a huge downturn
with the dissolution of the Soviet Union
now she would let you go pre-show to get
that host of Arty's going underground
now she returns II love to see you nice
to have a chat thank you
you